wo ist ein weg
es gibt doch nichts schöneres als
radfahrer pure freiheit pure
leidenschaft körper castoren
körperkraft
es gibt doch nichts schöneres als
radfahren pure freiheit pure
leidenschaft
es gibt doch nichts schöneres als live
band pure freiheit ihre leidenschaften
körper grafton 1 ist etwas passiert mir
nicht aber mein fahrrad und nein muss
ich jetzt einfach wahnsinn
java ist die fahrer spezialistin weil
ich daran liebe ja das gefällt die west
ja repariere alte fahrräder kaputte
bremsen defektes licht platte reifen
gebrochene herzen
wer aufmerksam ist ein furchtbarer text
ich weiß nicht was du sagst du brauchst
werden ja ich brauche gute fantasievolle
werbung
herr friese erhöht meine miete also
brauche ich mehr kunden sonst muss ich
den laden schließen
du kannst vielleicht eine werbeagentur
beauftragen was das kostet dass es viel
zu teuer
ich mache das lieber selbst ich brauche
zehn prozent mehr kunden sind dann aber
sehr viele oder genau und erreicht man
viele menschen im internet